for everybody's listening
when you think the world doesn't get it
and you're right and everyone's wrong
you're deep [ __ ] i've seen how that goes
right right yeah i'm very self-aware
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
vayner nation what is good uh my
commitment to have interesting people
that i want to chop it up with continues
in 2022
in personnel like you know we're
starting to kind of get there so we're
in the office uh
very creative dude here i'm gonna let
him introduce himself and and tell you a
little about himself but i have a fun
feeling that this is going to get into
some uh some good stuff right before we
started recording he just said oh [ __ ]
i'm getting old but he but he looks
great he looks super young and handsome
and
you're wrestling you wrestled uh is that
what your year is or no
every time i see that you know i tend to
be weird about like getting into fights
like i'm a i would hope so no let me
explain this there was a little bit of
like brooklyn where are you guys
brooklyn you were just queens there was
a little queen's love back here on the
production teams they were given and it
got very easy seth's accent even grew a
little bit did you hear that dustin seth
seth's queen's axe that count came out a
little bit when he figured out mike and
him were from the same neighborhood so
i grew up very jersey 80s and like got
into a lot of fights like that's how we
did it it was different and for some
reason
i still as a 46 year old man when i walk
around earth especially under sports
context where i know my emotions run
wild kind of size up people of like am i
willing to fight this person and when i
see the ear i'm never interested in
fighting smart man when i see the ear
i'm like that dude can do the [ __ ] that
i have no shot in because i'm going to
try to get one lucky punch in and when i
throw it i'm going to be on the ground
because you're going to shoot me and i'm
dead and i don't have the strength the
course drink is getting better but not
there and i'm [ __ ] finished so anyway
why don't you tell the vayner nation who
you are what you do give me a little
like comic book number one like a little
little four one origin story we'll get
into that yeah
yeah
but uh yeah name's brendan schaub i'm a
stand-up comedian podcaster
uh i'm the owner creator of uh thick boy
studios thick boy network where all my
shows are
based under that and uh
my number one profession is stand-up
comedian tour all over i just released a
special the gringo poppy on youtube on
my thick boy channel which was shot by
my team edited everything
fully integrated right everything man so
how do you think about that as a young
dude how old are you uh 38. so as a
young dude how do you think now yeah but
like you know maybe not 12 but like you
got you got [ __ ] 60 years on earth so
like 60 more mm-hmm
you're being generous name name the
biggest grandpa you know with
cauliflowers and full sleeve tattoos
well that's what i'm like that's what
every grandpa is going to look like in
60 years
at my size i'm like i'm like a great
dane dude no no no no i run hard man do
you have the mindset of like i'm going
to go in my 60s so [ __ ] go hard
uh i don't think i have that mindset i
think i'm realistic you know but i i do
take care of myself modern medicine's
insane bro i'm hoping [ __ ] that
everybody used to die from yeah it's
hard it's harder to die from they just
know how to do [ __ ] now true the the
lifespan is extensive gross every
[ __ ] day and now they're getting into
some weird ass [ __ ] like like i fee you
know do you know what my biggest fear on
earth is that that in like nine years
i'm gonna wake up and there's breaking
news everywhere and they're like we
figured it out and i'm in nine years
i'll be 55 so we figured it out
and if you're under 42 you can live
forever i'm gonna be so pissed so pissed
so pissed i'm gonna be like [ __ ]
that's super sad anyway so stand-up
comedy stand-up comedy yep when did that
hit the raid you're 30 and 40 so like
was there a stand-up comedian or was
there a moment or or did that come later
like when did stand-up comedy hit yeah
came later for me i uh background is
sports
got great size yeah background sports so
played division one football university
of colorado no [ __ ]
oh real [ __ ] football yeah that's a
real program oh yeah yeah big toy yeah
we were good too yeah when i was there
we were good and then i had a cappuccino
with the buffalo bills was how to had a
shot in the nfl stop mm-hmm good for you
you df-8 uh i was free free agent yeah
yeah and so you went to camp went to
camp what year was that that was that
been 2006.
talk to me about the pro so i'm in the
business we wrap a bunch of players
vaynersports as a matter of fact mike
mccartney uh is one of our agents his
dad is the legendary coach of colorado
mike mccarthy i know him very well so
yeah he's great he represent my best
friend uh who's draft in the second
round joe kloffenstein he's yeah the
best yeah so he just came over to
vaynersports he's great man we've been
chasing for five years you should so
pumped he's the best the best i
genuinely think he's the best agent
football agree 100 and i think you get
you obviously know him well so you know
what we were looking for which is like i
need a great agent but i need a better
human being because i can't [ __ ] around
with that [ __ ] 100 a lot of those agents
correct it's across the board in in
sports is
the best so anyway this is super fun
i i just got to ask you like that jump
you played d1 football
so that means you had a real high school
career where'd you grow up aurora
colorado so real high school career yes
to get to [ __ ] colorado
you you get you get to the place where
even getting signed as a free agent post
draft that is like a remarkable football
player like i don't think people
understand the scheme of eight billion
people you know and it took me i would
say you know i'm 38 i would say recently
in the past
three years it took me you know i've
have kids now when they asked me about
stuff it took me
a long time to have that perspective
where
man you did something a lot of people
didn't do because to get there the goal
is to be tom brady correct so by me not
playing in an actual and i thought you
failed i feel like a failure yeah that's
insane and then i get it then i go from
there
to compete in mixed martial arts i was
in the ufc i was a top 10 heavyweight in
the world and then i haven't talked
about fighting you know again probably a
long time i'd always shut it down with
people asking me about it
because again my goals became velasquez
you don't get to that level just being
like i i just want to be in the top 10.
that you can't settle for that so it's
taken a lot of work a lot of growth
where i can look at my career in
football in the ufc and realized that
man that was a that was a successful run
you did something pretty cool yeah good
for you yeah that makes me happy because
i think
i think there's i always think that my
level of ambition and competitiveness
there's a good side to it and a bad side
correct and i think for whatever reason
the circumstances of dna and parenting
and the luck of the draw i got lucky
like i want to be the greatest in the
world comma
whenever i don't achieve anything that
i'm like fully there for
there's a level of being content that i
[ __ ] went at it
that really gives me a little bit of
balance and i'm very aware that not
everyone that has the insanity of i
played basketball last night
i played once because i broke my foot at
the all-star game three years ago i've
only played once half-assed at the
garden the other day for a coinbase
event this was the first time i played
basketball in like three and a half
years four years last night for two
hours you would have thought this pickup
game my life depended on yeah i wanted
to win so bad it was like bleeding out
of my we lost the first game you can't
shut that off though
it's just in your dna i can't but but
to
what you've achieved like
i'm glad that you're at that place at
such a young age because there are
people who never like love themselves
enough to go there correct yeah and i
think also like i wouldn't change
anything like of course not if i would
have
got signed by the buffalo bills and had
a five or six year career or in the ufc
if i would have became champ or won my
last fight which was eight years ago i
you know i wouldn't be where i'm at now
correct which is to me my true calling
but i had to go through and my journey
to stand up and be in a headline comic
were you a class clown yes class clown i
grew up in aurora colorado which was
predominantly like a black neighborhood
so to fit in
sports was the thing and it was a
double-edged sword for me because i was
really i wasn't big as a kid i was
smaller but i was really athletic so i
knew i could make friends by showing
them how good i was at football sure but
my
my my heart and my passion was saturday
night live i was obsessed with it was
snl snl robin my mom would uh every
saturday would watch snl and then she
always had me watch robin williams so
she loved comedy she loved it that's
where i got my humor from my and she
introduced me all that stuff so
my heart wanted to be a comic but i was
really athletic it took me pla some
great places you also again based on
what i know about your athletic career i
didn't know i didn't know you you got to
go to camp
obviously i know about the ufc stuff um
i mean
that means in junior high or high school
you knew you had a shot
yeah i mean
you know but but again
you know when you're a kid and you're i
guess gifted at football the idea is to
be the next john elway or the next tony
gonzalez
so my entire kind of identity at the
time was surrounded to make it to the
nfl and i thought if they just give me a
shot man i'll be the next tony gonzalez
and then when you get there you know i
was young when you get there you don't
have that perspective you when you
my heart was broken i'm a sense of
person my heart was so broken when i got
there and realized it was such a
business it was so savage
because i thought i'd get there
you know it's willy wonka in the
chocolate factory man i'm the lucky one
to get the golden ticket this will be
great it's not great man it is such a
business it's hard i was the i was not
given a lot of opportunities which
of course but that's the business man
yeah so when your dream is to get to the
willy wonka's chocolate factory and i
get there and you realize it's this did
you get me did you get any pre-season
snaps no no i got hurt i got hurt yeah i
heard my hamstring went back home we had
some other uh they released me we had
some other offers to you know go to the
dolphins or practice
swat stuff and then
yeah i've always been realistic with
myself and i
i
i think
my best trait whatever it is
is i i never just identify as that so a
lot of athletes and you know this in the
line you're in a lot of athletes when
they get done playing or if it ends for
whatever reason god forbid they don't
know how to not identify as you know an
nba player right uh nfl player ufc
fighter i never saw myself as just that
ever ever ever ever do you think it's
because you had this other passion did
you do you feel subconsciously or maybe
consciously
in the back of your mind you're like i'm
going to get the comedy somehow
i think so i think so because also in
the ufc
i lost a fight and i knew like my
surroundings were a little bit toxic and
i need to make a change and i grew up in
venice beach as a kid i grew up in
venice beach and for whatever reason
when i'd get to la it just i don't know
what it is it felt like home even though
i wasn't born there but i grew up there
there's something about it the culture
just it just worked for you that's me
that was your place it's the way i feel
about new york yeah when people are like
you know now everyone's like you're
gonna move to puerto rico or miami the
taxes and all this like are you [ __ ]
out of your mind yeah like i couldn't
live anywhere in the world but new york
like i try to i can't i get it i get it
calls me back good for you so you knew
that so i when i moved to l.a
um i was a coach on ultimate fighter at
the time okay yeah that's right and so
when i was getting ready to move
um
during the ultimate fighter
one of the coaches nate markhart who's a
teammate of mine brought in a comedian
named brian callan he brought in brian
callan and brian's trying to make the
kids laugh right they're you know it's a
tough thing i was on the ultimate
fighter i was a contestant there was a
finalist on the ultimate fighter so i
know how hard it is for those kids so
they brought in a comic to make the kids
laugh yeah like
raise morale yeah and uh he's you know
kind of
i don't know roasting these guys or
whatever and then so i just kind of took
this you know took the floor and started
lighting him up and having this fun he's
like dude you're funny man i was like oh
thanks dude and he goes uh if you want
to come to the show tonight come on i
was like he doesn't know this i was like
thank god man i'd love to see the comedy
so i go see him and then he goes uh
man if you're ever in la hit me up man
and he loves the ufc so he knew who i
was so he goes if you're in l.a hit me
up it's funny say that i'm actually
moving there next week
he was hit me up so i uh i didn't want
to tell my family that in my head i knew
i was never coming back but i told them
i'm only going for a month just to see
camps and just hang out on my dog and
then i'll be back
was never happening so i moved out there
and then uh i stay at my uncle's place
and i remember i drove out i had no
friends i had no idea what i was going
to do
and uh brian how old were you this time
man probably 25 okay keep going yeah 20
maybe 25 24. i remember i get there and
you know i don't have anything man i
remember i didn't have a lot of money
none of that stuff living at my uncle's
house rent free felt like a loser coming
off a two-fight losing streak you know
so
i just remember i got to la and i
thought i made a terrible choice i'm
crying and i'm like man i don't know
anybody here what am i going to do and i
remember had brian's uh
cell phone number and i texted him hey
got to la i don't know if you remember
me man but you want to meet for coffee
tomorrow it was like the only glimpse of
hope i had and he responded back way too
fast way too eager i was like yeah and
sent me the address like oh jesus christ
so i meet him there
yeah way too eager and so i meet him
there and then him by the way i'm also
extremely eager like
all the cadence of what's appropriate
like if i love someone or i just want to
like i don't give a [ __ ]
i and i i think that's as as big and as
famous and successful you are i think
it's rare because there's this i'm the
same way there's this weird dance that
people do it's like an ego thing i know
but when i text you because i i've been
a fan for a while when i text you
um
you text me right back see because i
figured i'd text you and then you know
two days ago and by the way on the
record for people listening who i
haven't texted back
like when you get 100 or 200 like
sometimes you just get unlucky and you
miss [ __ ] yeah so thank god for this
story purposes because if i see it
correct at the time otherwise you're
moving at a million miles an hour it's
hard it's hard
you know it's like you're just the way
it is anyway so yeah so uh
me and bryan meet for coffee and he's
like man you're really funny interesting
and he at the this is
12 years ago he goes uh man you should
come on my podcast
podcast right right he said that's like
radio but you record it and i'm like all
right dude so i go to his house out of
his garage and you know it's this little
thing no video at the time
and we do the podcast and we get done
he's like dude that's the best pockets
we have this weird chemistry i'm like i
guess and he's like we should was that
you protecting yourself
the i guess
yeah or did you see it uh no i i'm
scared to like i mean
after you talk to so many people you
might be a nose again i think one of the
things that
um
one of the talents i have is i make
friends really easily so you and i are
we're going to be fred like i believe i
know you don't have time but we're going
to be friends
by the way friends the number one thing
i fight for is relationships me too i
don't know
i don't have a lot of time yeah because
i try to fight for relationships
in whatever form face time physical like
you know like i i agree with you like
that's what i fight for yeah yeah so you
weren't sure you were like maybe i'm
just charismatic and he likes me maybe i
don't have the skill set uh a little bit
yeah for sure especially to run media
you know especially at the time big
yeah in the background so he goes uh we
should do a podcast every week together
once a week and at the time remember i'm
i'm still in the ufc i'm pursuing a
world championship
and i don't have time for that man he
goes no no i'm telling you once a week
it's an hour two seconds yeah and i was
like uh
and he goes we'll talk about fighting
and and that's and i went hey listen
i'll do it but i don't want to talk
about just fighting we can touch on it
but i want to talk you know i'm into
fashion i'm a sneaker head you know i
like want to be myself i just wanted to
be like the lifestyle things like sure
so we start doing that thing you know
getting attraction i know at the time
especially there's like rogan marc maron
i remember corolla and then us you guys
were really really firing the kids so
that thing just kind of took off and
then remember i still compete in the ufc
but
i realized there like i had a knack for
it and then we started doing live firing
the kid live podcast
and uh brian would go
uh we're not gonna sit down and talk
like we do it's gonna be a performance
and i go yeah i say that makes sense man
he goes and here's what we're gonna do i
want you to start every show and you're
really good at storytelling i just want
you to tell a story every show 10
minutes a story i mean i can do that
and then you know few shows go by we're
doing big venues like you know my first
time ever on stage i'm at the vic
theater in chicago like sold out and so
those were my open mics but at the time
the way he framed it just telling
stories man you can tell stories
and i'll never forget we're we're some
big-ass theater in seattle or something
like that neptune and i go oh man i'm
trying to go over my story man it's like
10 minutes for the show i'm trying to go
over my story of story i hear he goes oh
bubba you're doing stand-up i just want
you to be scared and it clicked like
holy [ __ ] and then
he does he didn't realize at the time
what that meant to me everything here we
go dude that's it this is it on your
home this is it and then shortly after
that i'll wrap it up shortly after that
we do a a live fire in the kid
at the comedy store the best comedy
store which is like the map yeah it's
the [ __ ] it's like the garden yeah
i've always wanted to be there and oh
[ __ ] i don't even do stand up i'm like i
got to do the comedy story yeah all my
friends are there yeah it's it you know
it's a big feather in your cap so we do
a live friday kit there and it goes well
and i do my 10 minutes at the top
a few weeks ago by i get a call from the
booker emily never forget this changed
my life she goes hey see if you want to
do a spot in the belly room on wednesday
you have six minutes and in my head and
i respond back this how oblivious i was
i responded back to go oh let me check
with brian he might be out of town she
goes no dude we saw your set do it we
want you to come here and do it i was
like oh
[ __ ] the comedy store so i go there and
that was like my first technical set
which was almost eight years ago yeah
it's awesome and it was off then then
again you give me an inch you just give
me an inch get that i'm gonna freaking
run with it man back to if you could
have gotten some snaps and pretty that
which is probably why it probably burnt
yeah let's talk about that i want to
give i've been very hot on this new
thesis of giving out roses while
everyone's alive
like explain that i just see people
dying and just like outpours and just
like even like forget about famous
people kobe prince david bowie just like
in my life like you know i got into the
liquor business when i was a kid a lot
of people were 40 when i was 14 and you
know or 70 and just watched people that
i grew up in in business i was so young
you know pass because they were in their
50s when i met them and i was 20.
and
and i just something that just hit me
which is like
we tend to hold in
the roses how we feel genuinely feel
yeah and i think we
society right now is very good at
pointing fingers and razzing each other
and so i'm just you know i always think
i'd love to talk about that eventually
yeah so i'm very excited about just like
giving out roses so i have a fun a
couple fun questions for you on roses
you go to camp
buffalo
or maybe it happened in college because
that would make sense it depends on how
much time you spent at camp before you
got hurt um
who was the best football player that
you ever saw like if i said who's the
best football player
that i played with or against
you saw
that you saw with your own eyes from the
field not in the crowd so that means
maybe it was in camp with the bills
maybe it was against the best team you
played when you were at colorado because
it obviously takes it you know given
that you played a colorado and went to
camp you've seen professional football
players play so if i just said best
player you saw play uh there's a
two-part question there so played
against that i saw in person uh it would
be one a one b it'd be uh adrian
peterson which i didn't i didn't realize
at the time how he so we played oklahoma
when in the big 12 championship when
they had jason white heisman trophy
winner and then adrian pierson heisman
trophy winner yeah then went on to win
the national championship we play him
the game before yep and i i knew he was
good obviously you know we saw film on
him stuff like that when i saw him in
person
you know you're talking just felt
different he looked different moved
different you're just like
i get it he's such a tank and the speed
and he's big
and then can he's agile and you're just
like oh my god you're like that is a
star football player yeah i was like
that's that's a different dude yeah but
even that that that didn't discourage me
because i was like that's an all problem
yeah yeah i don't know i just need to be
a goddamn team yeah yeah and then
play uh one b with someone who i played
with and even that's one b1c would be uh
joe kloffenstein who was my roommate and
best friend he was drafted by the rams
mccarthy was his uh agent and uh he
played i think seven years in the nfl
and you're just a complete freak freak i
mean you're talking again my best friend
the worst diet you've ever seen eats
dumping donuts every morning six six
260 shredded it's frustrating
doesn't you know donuts yeah didn't give
a [ __ ] just eats whatever shred it and
then ran up four five three in the 40 at
260. insane the combine he takes his
shirt off you're like jesus ufc mma
who
hurt you the most on a single punch
again in the octagon
roses like roses yeah roses
you know with a little roses punch you
in the face roses this is like this is
really nice
you know and you know this i mean you
know it's better than i grew up a huge
fight fan
like boxing yeah and so when you i mean
i watched you i watched ufc number one
when it was a [ __ ] you know because i
was the right age
yeah i was like [ __ ] crazy and then
uh vaynersports is also in the fight
game we re we rep al jamaine sterling
uh o'malley like we have a water
michelle like we have a real practice
stipe like we have a big practice yeah
i'd love to talk to you about this yeah
we'll talk about that so so
you know you know this like what's funny
about punches is sometimes it's the
equilibrium it's like the back of it
exactly you can get drilled here and be
ok but the back of the head catches
people even i just did to myself i'm a
little like you know like so it's not
like it's just a weird sometimes it's
just a weird thing so correct and i
think this might surprise people that
are familiar with my career cause you
know uh antonio nogueira big nog i
thought in brazil yep and uh you know he
knocked me out yep but it didn't hurt i
understand
but when i got hit by uh roy nelson
he landed a right hand um he threw a
double jab and then a right hand it hit
me flushed that was the first time where
it were inside that gun because you're
drilling so high so high that's the
first time i was like oh can't do that
again jesus christ
that hit me right in the chin yep and uh
you know first fight in the technically
in the ufc because the ultimate fighter
they don't count fights yeah so that was
the finale jon jones was the co-maid of
yeah
it's roy nelson yeah yeah and uh i was
when the fight he lands that and i was
like oh holy oh wow this is real dude
you know the first time i've been
hitting a fight i know this is real and
then uh he lands the one that uh ended
up winning the fight and but that that
one didn't hurt is behind you to your
point yeah behind the air but you lose
the equity yeah but the the one that was
flush with from roy nelson yeah
when you talk about roses
which i which i absolutely love i would
say that's one thing that i do well i
tell especially close friends every time
whether it's text when we leave i love
you man i do it too i love you i'm a big
fan i love you man every and it might be
off for some people it's awkward as [ __ ]
i love you man like what did you guys do
i've done it to you guys like was it was
it weird the first time
first time it was right
you don't yeah it's so now like i've
only in the last five i i've been doing
it for so long like my college friends
are like because i like brought it up
like they're like you did that in
college i'm like i did like i've been
doing it for so long me too but then i
just thought i was gay
but it was like you know it's like it's
cool now but it's really nice
it's yeah but i think it it it's how you
grew up you know i think there's a lot
of it has to do with your parents being
comfortable with that stuff so if you do
it to someone that did not grow up with
that love and affection that's where
they're like geez take it easy dude talk
to you i just met you two days ago i get
it i love you man
talk to me about stand up
biggest
like obviously it's such an adrenaline
thing it's like so cool like i've i've
thought about stand up even though the
way i give keynotes is very affected by
eddie murphy and chris rock and
especially richard pryor who i was
obsessed with and i've seen those and
this is your roses is what you're so
brilliant at and which what makes
your favorite comic so brilliant too is
they can get from point a to b
with the with cutting the fat so they
get it's very clear and they can get
there where most people can't so if you
look at a nate bargettes you look at
bill burr
christa stefano they're great at getting
to where they need to get in the
shortest amount of time with the shorts
amount of words but they're very
powerful and you my friend are
damn good at that
thank you talk to me about the biggest
or if i said name a biggest laugh
because it might be hard you've been
like you know but like that like
the first time you work on like what's
what i find fascinating is the work i'm
so improv like when i think about rap
i'd be like oh i'd be going off the top
of the dome like you know like go into
the studio bang it out and be out yeah
other people really write yes
you know obviously the same thing with
comics there's different styles yeah big
time
tell me a story because this would be
this is a fun story for me something you
really worked on
and it [ __ ] destroyed
uh does anything come to mind if i ask
you that yeah it does because i think
you know they
any comics especially in new york you
know there's so many legends here
they'll tell you you really don't find
your voice on stage until you've been to
10 years so around seven the only caveat
with that is
remember especially when those older
heads started they were doing open mics
and stuff for me to get on stage
so the amount of time i've spent on
stage in seven years probably equal to
most comedians 12 to 14 years doing it
because i was
and i'm super blessed and i'm not taking
this for granted but because i had
somewhat of a name yeah i was able to
get on stage more than these other
comments
so as far as biggest laugh i i
i'll have some i'll have something
written down in my head where i think it
and i have to learn the hard way where
i'll have it written out word for word
and i'd study that uh do in the mirror
do something
yeah you get out and be like jesus
christ dude yeah and then once i loosen
up and i'm just going over you got the b
you got the core of it now if you if you
look at my notes that are in my phone or
on my paper it's just bullet points and
then i can riff from there and i know
the beats and stuff that makes sense so
i've had times where i've written it out
i thought i was going to crush and i did
it and then i'll i'll just kind of cap
go you know right field with it and have
fun with it and it you know for me
especially during now seven years once i
start telling like my truth like being
married to latina and having mexican
kids and being a dad like once i start
telling stand up that's actually
relatable to the audience i found for me
like i was getting laughs where i didn't
think it was going to be like being a
dad
like i didn't think but that's what
works of course
when i have an idea and it hits me and
i'm like i'm gonna try it out tonight
whether it's at the comedy store i have
to follow you know crystalia or mark
maron or louis c.k the other night at
the hollywood improv and if you i try
something new and i get this huge laugh
dude it's like
there's has to be like a home run it has
to be like home run 100 yeah you're like
oh i got some and i can elaborate on
this what about acting
you think you have that gear in you are
you interested in that gear or do you
think that's like a different thing
altogether that you're like whatever
yeah i would never disrespect and i was
like oh i can act but i do think you
know i i've i've had a small role in a
david ayers movie um and i think did you
like it i saw the sausage was made yeah
it was i my takeaway from that i think
again i can i think there's positives
with everything you know i was basically
an extra i played a cartel guy they had
me in a mascot
you know i look like a giant mexican
cartel member
and uh
it's just so serious and i'm not that
serious of a person and it was like
hurry up and wait
you just took it i hurried i did i did a
show called planet of the apps for apple
like years ago with will i am
jessica alba and gwyneth paltrow and i
was the fourth judge and like those are
like big ass names and it was on apple
and i had dreams that they were gonna
buy netflix before they aired the show
like i had all these concepts like four
people watched it because they put on
apple music
but we did the show and
i just couldn't believe how slow it was
yeah i'm too much of a
psycho of speed do you think it's a uh
control thing
i just think the tv has its way they
know what they're trying to get
like it's a it's a it's a platform thing
yeah i think you're right on that and i
think for me it was like uh
a bit of an ego check too which i didn't
you know care about because shyla buffs
on set and all these big actors and
seeing them again the positive was i i
saw how good shyla but i saw him die in
the movie and they had to do it eight
times and that was the only thing they
shot all day and my scene got cut at the
time so i'm just watching him
i just i appreciate talent so much when
i i would watch him it's like oh my god
this guy is
so talented and then david ayers who did
you know training day and uh end of
watch and
fury like such a monster and suicide
squad
i and i told him this and we don't know
each other well but i told him this i
said i've had some great coaches in my
life man as far as being able to manage
like when it comes to football like
being a head coach and be able to manage
all these personalities and you know the
offense coordinator defense coordinator
and putting a game plan together i said
you're the the best i've seen as far as
communication being direct with guys and
but also not being too harsh knowing
exactly what works with this actor and
that actor said i've never seen anything
like him man you're a head coach you're
you're an offense coordinator man it's
cool yeah so that so that was cool but
to your point
yeah the hurry up and wait and it was so
serious i think it was like a a comedy
thing with my friends which we could do
i think i'd be so much fun i'd be
interested in that but
um yeah you know i i think media is
moving where everyone has their niche
and there's these lanes and you know
if it depends you know but if you can
control the narrative and control what
you want to put out well that's the
market to me like i take pride in that i
was listening carefully to like hey i
put out a special and it's like i'm in
full control that's very different than
doing it on netflix or hulu or something
of that nature
i value that i'd rather have less
distribution and more control
and and i again i'm a fan here so one of
the reasons i said that is because i if
anybody could
relate to that and and
and you know and be like oh that's cool
it would be you because i have a lot of
awareness
with no massive distribution channel
it's been all done in the trenches yeah
because i think the collective of the
trenches linkedin and tick tock and
youtube and podcast and twitter and
instagram
collectively if you do it the way i do
it
adds up to some of the biggest
distribution plays it's hard like i'm
empathetic that i like have
good
improv uh chameleon contextual skills to
play all those channels
but it's cool for everybody listening
right now like it's hard to play the
game of distribution because you have to
be picked
it gets diluted it needs to work for the
distributor and that loses a lot of soul
correct and you know with comedy
especially with with my background man
being an athlete and having cauliflower
ears and full sleeve tattoos and i you
know i dress like a [ __ ] boy for like a
better term yeah i'm a sneaker head you
know i look ridiculous so you know being
this big the fact that we both have
backwards hat and tv
like i got excited i put on backwards
just so we look exactly like yeah
but um
you know so for you know when i first
started you know i'm a tough sell man
yeah and i get that so
my goal it's the same you know that
right
interrupt that right there
that little sentence and i get that
is the number one thing that i see for
all the kids that are listening right
now i want to rewind that part
i know we don't edit so you don't have
to rewind it but
literally the and i get that
i
so much has been like filled in for me
from watching from afar listening to you
in this podcast i believe that
what you just said is the most important
part of your success i believe it's the
most important part of my success
we have ambition we have drive we want
to make things happen but [ __ ]
self-awareness for you to say blah blah
blah but i get that
for everybody's listening
when you think the world doesn't get it
and you're right and everyone's wrong
you're in deep [ __ ] i've seen how that
goes right right yeah i'm very
self-aware so you know when i'm doing
spots at the comedy store
i again i think maybe because you know
i'm very uh closely associated with joe
rogan and joey diaz and tom segura and
crystal the big dog so they would treat
me a different way where really i
shouldn't have been treated like that
and again i'm very aware like i don't
deserve this treatment so you were like
turtle in like entourage like the halo
yeah dude i was the punter on the
football team like i'm on the team but i
don't really deserve a ring you know
what i'm saying i'm not going through
the trenches like these guys getting you
know but i'll get there the humility of
that like again i'm i'm sorry but i
really want to drill this for the people
listening on the other side
not getting a high on your own like i
you know it's not obvious you have to
kind of know me but like no doubt
it is humility that is making my whole
[ __ ] engine go yes i'm confident as
[ __ ] i got bravado i [ __ ] go at it
right but [ __ ] it is humility like
genuinely knowing i don't mean [ __ ] yeah
like i'm very aware like i see it and
it's a [ __ ] superpower so for listen
you may think you're special you got it
that's awesome confidence is everything
you [ __ ] match it up with real
[ __ ] self-awareness and humility
which leads that self-awareness leads to
patience like i get that i'm not
everyone's cup of tea yet yeah that i'm
gonna have to earn it they're gonna have
to get to know me under the hood
that's [ __ ] powerful for all these
kids my main thing was when i got around
all those comics when i was doing comedy
and i knew it was gonna be a tough sell
for a lot of people i my number one goal
was i'm gonna earn the respect to my
peers and the only way by doing that is
they see me working my ass on the field
yeah so i would go up to the book or
whether it was the improv or laugh
factor the ice house or the comedy store
and go hey all i'll be a door guy man
i'll be a door guy and i'll i'll work
however you want me to work and i do not
care i'll go on it and you knew they
were going to say yes that they look at
him like yeah you're a door guy right
i'll get smart i'm going out tomorrow
i'll go on at midnight
just let me do the work let me earn my
keep here and if it's not a fit if you
think i'm bad at this let me know man
but i'm telling you give me an inch i'm
gonna take a mile humility yeah tell me
about this tour before we get out of
here tell you about what you're
charlotte and all this stuff you're
about oh yeah yeah yeah so uh you know
it's a whole new hour after the special
uh the special is the gringo poppy on
youtube thick boy youtube and uh the
tour you know i'm in charlotte this
thursday friday saturday then i go to
philly and then it's portland and i'm
all over man but a whole whole new house
where can people find that in case they
want to go check it out uh come on your
social media uh where's the best place
to find it uh youtube what's the tour
and when to win uh non-stop i mean
you're going yeah non-stop
you love it
oh obsessed but again it's a balance
because you have kids so it's like i
struggle with this balance where
i don't want to miss anything with my
kids life because they're six and two
and then also being the next can i say
something like that might help you sure
please there was this young woman in the
in singapore after a talk i gave i was
with my sister on this trip and just
some of the people from the organizers
we went to this dinner and there was
like 20 people at the table and this
young maybe she was 25 she talked about
her mother being a judge
i think it was singapore it might have
been malaysia
and she talked about her mom working
every minute
and i was like really listening because
obviously you know i also want to go at
it
and she said
you know it was hard at times as a kid
she goes
but my mother showed me how to live
instead of told me how to live yes
i really think for a lot of the parents
that are listening out there there is no
work-life balance there's just work-life
balance for you
it all looks different it's all
individual
but i i do think that a lot of parents
in their concern anxiety of like am i
doing it right yes
really miss that nuance that that young
lady by example yeah
like you know
it's a really interesting insight that
i've like
took that nugget and then have watched
for the last four five seven years
it really
resonates and i think for people that
are on fire
trying to do [ __ ]
it's gonna impact your kids more than
you think now that doesn't mean miss
every [ __ ] recital and game and never
be there and [ __ ] like that i'm telling
you i i can't you know i there's a and i
was talking to burke christ i don't know
if you know bert but you know burke goes
man you know i've missed so much of my
kids childhood and and i said
what i struggle with bert is so this the
longest ever been away from my kids on
doing this press tour and i go to on
tour
you know that's a full week seven days
uh and i need to talk to somebody about
it i i get physically ill if i don't see
my kids yeah yeah
and you're lucky compared to parents
of different generations face time's
crazy like it's a crazy revelation yeah
for parents that are on the road there's
a lot of things i get it good for you
you know yourself i mean look i'm
incredibly close to my dad like [ __ ]
love him to like oh like [ __ ]
built his business because i loved him
like wanted it for him and and
i didn't even see my dad in the first 15
years of my life
even though he slept in the same roof as
me every night he just left before i
woke up and got home after i went to
sleep he worked that much
and so obviously i'm very affected by
that i'm like there's just you know i
know kids who despise their parents or
struggle with them and they were with
them every day and they went to
everything so
intent and love
trumps everything but that that one
thing
of like she showed me how to live
really struck with me all right my
team's hovering all over me i got a ton
of [ __ ] to do all right man no dude
nothing i appreciate i'm enjoying the
[ __ ] of this yeah we'll chop up again
appreciate it
[Music]